today across Europe a new virus is
spreading fake news and disinformation
about coronavirus the Internet is awash
with Kovan 19 conspiracy theories and
false claims like the EU is doing
nothing for people suffering from
coronavirus false the European Union has
no mandate when it comes to health care
but it is finding concrete ways to help
the EU has put forward 8 packages for
research and to reduce the social and
economic toll that coronavirus is taking
as well as threatening our health by
spreading unproven remedies
disinformation undermines trust in our
democracy the EU is fighting back
it has pressured tech giants like
Facebook Twitter Google and Microsoft to
stop the spread of fake news about covin
19 the companies have pledged to combat
falsehoods about the pandemic and
prioritize reliable information members
of parliament have voiced their concerns
about the dangers of the rise in fake
news
[Music]
the --use anti disinformation taskforce
has gathered hundreds of cases where
pro-kremlin actors have been using the
crisis to sow division in the EU the
media has reported that Chinese
officials are also trying to exploit the
crisis just like coronavirus it's
everyone's responsibility to stop the
spread of fake news check sources such
as EU versus disinfo the European Centre
for disease prevention and control and
the World Health Organization as well as
other official reliable sources before
sharing information
[Music]